what is going on everyone uh today we're
going to talk about a fun topic
which is uh i got a message yesterday
from somebody who said uh you know who's
dead broke
and was like what do i do all that kind
of stuff and so um
i think i've talked in the past i'll
probably do another one about when i
when i've lost everything
um what i did step by step um
to i think the after i lost everything
the next month i did 110 000
in sales um and now sorry not sales that
was cash collected in the next
in the next 30 days so like you
absolutely just need skills
you can have nothing else in your life
and a beautiful thing is that no
government can take it from you
no person can take your skills from you
in a divorce um
those are always your own uh which is
something that i don't know for some
reason feels magical to me
and so one of the things that i've seen
as i've kind of you know
moved moved up i'm not saying that
arrogantly just you know just
developed progressed whatever um is that
the people who i surround myself with
now have more money than
the people that i surrounded myself when
i was early on in my career and what's
ironic is that these people
actually spend less money they
they have they have less desire to spend
money
and they find ways to acquire things for
less money out of pocket
and that's always really interesting to
me
and so right now i think there's you
know if you were to if you were to look
at quote investment opportunities right
um you could you could you know
invest in buying a house so let's say
let's say you've got i'll do two
scenarios
all right let's say you've got fifty
thousand dollars all right
and you're like okay i'm thinking about
buying uh a house
right and i think for first house you
might only have to put ten percent down
i'm not sure it's 10 or 20. i don't
remember but anyways let's just say 10
for
for sake of whatever so 500 000
house all right you put 10 down and then
you get the mortgage right you get the
liability of
the mortgage payment every month yippee
um
now if you were to if you were to and
let's say that in order for you to save
that you've been making
i don't know 60 grand a year and you've
been saving that for you know five years
something like that
now let's look at an alternative
scenario where you
um are still making that same amount of
money 60 and you saved up 50.
and instead of buying a house you have a
long conversation with your spouse and
you say or maybe you don't have a spouse
whatever with yourself and you say
i wonder how much money i could get for
this money
ah interesting right and so
you you you leaf through the businesses
that are in your area and by the way
the best way to do that is one you
should contact brokers not necessarily
to buy a business but to get an idea of
some of the businesses
that are in the area and what price
ranges look like but if you buy from a
broker you're going to pay retail you
could definitely negotiate a deal and
i'll tell you one of the deals that i
did that was
really good at the end of this but uh
anyways so let's say you you know you
reach out to some businesses things that
you like or enjoy or feel like you have
some specialized knowledge in
and uh you find out that there's a
business that's doing
let's say i don't know
250 000 a year in uh
in in profit right and uh because it's a
small
local owned business and you're not
going to pay retail for it
you get it for two and a half you know
times
earnings right which would be uh what's
two and a half times
uh it's 525 hopefully i think two and a
half no that's 625 excuse me
625 000 is what a business you might pay
for a business that's doing 250 000
a year in profit all right now here's
where here's where it's interesting
right
so i had um an early mentor who who
taught me this negotiation tactic that
i've used pretty much
for throughout my entire life since this
moment and i used it in the deal that
i'll tell you about
in a second which is agree on price then
agree on terms right
and so when you when you would go to
quote talk to this business right
there's there's the price which you
might say cool you know this business
625
and then there's terms right and so the
term side once you've agreed on the
price you negotiate down whatever
and then you say okay well i'm going to
need you to sell our finance meaning
you're not going to pay anything you're
paying over time
right i need you to sell or finance uh
you know three quarters of the deal all
right
and so three quarters of the deal man
i'm doing some math today but like 400
and you know 30-ish
437 whatever thousand dollars um
and you're gonna finance that for you
know three years
right and then on top of that
or five years you can do whatever you
want here i think
i mean you could probably i mean you try
and push it out as far as you can right
and then what you have remaining which
would be like in this instance 200
000 then you get a note from the bank
right or sba loan which you have a 200
000 um
loan for it and you put your your fifty
thousand dollars down right so then that
would be
two hundred uh so you put fifty which
would be twenty five percent of two
hundred thousand
so i'm going to recap this 625 is the
cost of the business
you know 437 you get seller finance
meaning you can pay that over time
and then you've got two hundred thousand
dollars that you get a loan from the
bank so
uh which you put fifty thousand dollars
for so if you're thinking about this
the guy who's selling the business he
sells for 625 but he's only getting 200
000 up front
you're only putting 50 of that 200 and
you're taking a loan for the rest of it
right um and so when you're looking at
this
you've now acquired this business that
makes 250 000
a year right so you upgraded your income
from 60 to 250 000
right and within you know 24 months
all of that you know income will be
yours and maybe hopefully you'll grow it
or you'll probably try and work extra
hard and take over some of the
some of the other positions or cut out
some of the waste etc in the business
and uh and and so that
massively speeds you up in life right
and if you compare that to
what it would cost you to start your own
business
um in terms of investment and like
existing book of business
client lists all the knickknacks you
have to buy that you don't even think of
zoning permits and all the fees and
licenses
it's actually pretty decent deal so um
i'll tell you one of the deals that i
did that was pretty good so i had four
locations at this point this is one of
the gyms and i opened a fifth location
so the first two locations
i opened i opened the first one i think
for forty thousand dollars i mean i put
i didn't i put as little as i possibly
could in this thing um
and it happened to have been an old gym
so there was like turf already in the
flooring was already in it was painted
like there was a bunch of things i
didn't have to pay for so
i lucked out there um and but the second
one because i thought i was smarter
i put 200 we put 250 000 into the second
location
and here's the fun thing it made no more
money than the first location did
uh which i always think is hilarious so
like uh to the undisciplined everything
looks like a spending opportunity
uh and so i pretty much would empty my
bank account
and uh and so on my fifth location uh my
next two locations were corporate
locations which were actually pretty
cheap
um which was pretty cool those are those
are good deals but the
the the fifth location that i did i had
a gym that went out of business or he
not out of business he wanted to
uproot because his it got divorced or he
had some some
family crisis and so he was looking for
someone to buy
his his gym and so it was beautiful it
had all this equipment that was really
expensive in it and i was like man this
is like a dream come true
and so i agreed on price because i had
my mentor talk me through this i agreed
on price which i think was 40
000 i think it was 40 great it was 40 or
50. i think it was yeah
so that's what i agreed and then i was
like cool i'll pay you over the next
year
and he was like fair enough and so i
mean he didn't say like that we
negotiated and then
12 months is what we what we came to and
so i mean i tried to go for 24 months
uh but he agreed on 12. and so the
beautiful thing with that
was i didn't i didn't put any money out
of pocket
so you know my first year i put 50 grand
in second gym i put 250 000
in fifth gym smarter more experienced me
puts no money in
right and in the first 30 days we did 51
000 in sales
so this gym in the first 30 days
literally paid for itself
period right and so this thing that is
now kicking off profit
right every month during this during
this whole period of time
and then 12 months later i ended up
meeting russell and telling him
how i was doing this stuff and he's like
you should be teaching other people how
to do what you're doing now
and so i ended up selling the gym for
one and a half times more than i quote
bought it for
right which i then had the gym pay for
it on its own
and so i basically acquired a cash
flowing asset for nothing
and then had just acquired a cash
flowing asset for
for no money and so i think about that
um
in light of the original thing that i i
mentioned was just like i get
i get people who message me all the time
like what what happens if i don't have
any money
i don't know what to do you always have
to just get skills or this is just my
opinion is that because there's no one
who can take them from you there's no
divorce
there's no government there's no
revolution there's no financial crisis
that can ever take your skills from you
and that's why when entrepreneurs hit
zero
they can usually bounce back i've done
it i had eleven hundred dollars in my
bank account
um at one point at my at my lowest point
after i had six gyms
right um after this so even when i had
this experience and it sounds cool like
i
messed up and um you know that's why i
think i love to say
you only should only have to get rich
once and um
and that's why people who are wealthy
are more risk averse because the
downside risk of losing everything is
always bigger
right like you can reverse 30 years of
great decisions with any
number multiplied by zero any number
multiplied by zero
you could have a billion dollars if you
make a bad investment it goes to zero
right
and so that's why when people are like i
don't know why you're motivated and i
don't know why
uh there like it's just there's there's
just always things that can happen you
know what i mean and so just being risk
averse is what i have noticed from the
people who have the most money
is that they actually have way lower
risk tolerances than the people who have
no money uh which is hilarious because
it's like the people who have the least
amount of money
uh then go buy lottery tickets which are
literally the worst investment you could
possibly make
and and and they they consistently
invest
their money in a terrible investment
that has all the downside risk of going
to zero
whereas the richest people in the world
find things that could never go to zero
and they buy them for zero
so think about that for a second people
are using their money poor people
use their money to buy things that have
virtually guaranteed you know risk of
going to zero
right with tiny risk of of upside right
whereas rich people buy stuff for
zero dollars that have um
upside potential but that doesn't that
doesn't have a billion dollar upside
potential they would rather have a
guaranteed small return
with no risk than a potential for huge
return
with guaranteed risk think about that so
uh anywho i think if over time and it's
not like you can shift your perspective
on this overnight it took me a long time
and i still am doing it now
um in shifting how like because i still
get excited about you know
i see these you know these these these
cryptocurrencies 20xing and stuff you
know in like a month and i'm like man
that's crazy um but then i also think
like
well the downside risk of me going to
zero
is far more upsetting to me than me
getting 20 times more on
some tiny investment that i would make
um and so
i i don't do it right and so anyways um
i say all this to say uh agree on price
agree on terms
try and get something for nothing see if
you're gonna if you're gonna make an
investment in any kind or you're trying
to start a business there's usually a
business that's already for sale or has
a motivated seller
an owner who doesn't want to do it
anymore who almost give it to you for
free
right and that's the thing is when
you're new you're getting so excited but
you're not patient
right that's why you have to have the
character traits of being successful
before you will see the success
because if you if you have that
character trait you'll look and you'll
say i can take six months because in the
in the decade of my in the next decade
of my life there's no rush
but me making a good deal or a bad deal
of like
should i put all my investment in this
thing or should i be able to get
something that makes four times more
money for free
you can do that you can do that and i'm
telling you i talk to business owners
every day i mean guys making a million
two million four million dollars a year
who literally have told me they're like
dude if someone came today and offered
me
like guys who are making a million
dollar a million dollars a year in
profit
like if someone had offered me 200 grand
right now i would take it i just i'm so
tired of this business
so like there are opportunities they're
just not listed anywhere you just got to
look for them right
and that's the thing no one will do it
because it's work so but the good news
is that if you have a little bit of work
ethic you can make a tremendous amount
of money
with very little risk and do it the way
the rich people that i know
do it so otherwise have an amazing day
keeping awesome i'll catch you guys
upside bye